very few High School sweethearts really
last what do you attribute to the
success of that we met when she was 14 I
was 15. and for whatever reason we've
somehow matched and grown together
through all the different seasons that
we've gone through the first season of
that was me being a high school
douchebag and not being the type of
person I'm proud of today but her
sticking with me through that and
helping me grow as an individual and
then the next season was like we were in
college and we were far apart from one
another she was in New York City I was
in the Bay Area and really struggling
through long distance then we got
engaged and she moved out to the Bay
Area we had our first season of living
together and that was this new exciting
thing and now we're in the next season
of that which is raising a child
together and so I feel like at every
stage we've sort of grown closer and
gotten to know each other better in a
different context and in a different way
and experience new challenges together
but a lot of it is just luck